it's cpr awareness week and the red
cross is recognizing two officers for
their quick action they took to save a
life mary jane bellissa has our story
[Music]
it was quick thinking on trooper
christopher french and officer mike
smith's part that helped save a man's
life back in january 2020. trooper
french with the nevada highway patrol
responded to a reckless driving call
when he arrived he found a car stopped
in the middle of i-15 near flamingo the
driver was unconscious and not breathing
trooper french blocked traffic with his
car and immediately began performing cpr
there's no time to really think
how are we going to react to the
situation we do what we're trained to do
less than 10 minutes later officer smith
arrived to assist him with cpr once the
ambulance arrived they even followed the
man to the hospital we hope that the
outcome in the end is the best
and it was in this in this circumstance
i followed him to the hospital contacted
his family
waited there for the family to get there
made sure everything was set and he
understood everything that went on
before i even left i am so happy it made
me want to cry actually i found out that
he lived i'm like this guy
i thought for sure he was dead
once we put him on the ambulance i
thought he was dead but find out he was
alive forget about it that's awesome the
pair are now being hailed as heroes on
saturday the red cross presented their
life saving award for their efforts as
being trained to use cpr can make all
the difference between life and death
situations i really appreciate it i
still believe in the community the
community believes in law enforcement
and
having those personal partnerships with
the community as well as private
industry and other agencies is wonderful
and it feels really good to be
recognized mary jane balleza live local
now
cpr and first aid training classes are
also available at the red cross